has your 1% life gotten a little ho-hum
as being a billionaire turns you soft
well what Conda just opened up to the
world and it's ready to knock you down a
few pegs you use Jared Kushner's
personal chef and you were a first-round
draft pick for the Illuminati softball
team everything is perfect a little too
perfect until now
welcome to Wakanda the recently opened
East African nation would like to invite
you on their self-esteem annihilation
tour for the 1% there is no better cure
for the inevitable ennui that comes from
chronic entitlement than a confidence
crushing visit to the most attractive
stylish and technologically advanced
country on planet earth upon your
arrival to a Conda you'll be handed a
piece of the strongest most valuable
metal on earth vibranium it will then
immediately be taken away from you
because you can't be trusted
don't attach anything that reaction you
have is called disappointment isn't it a
rush to feel a feeling again a person's
worth cannot be measured and how fast
they run or and how hard they hit but if
it was rest assured Kingda Ka is
demonstrably better than you in every
way physically morally and sexually oh
you surf in your free time cool he surfs
on cars do you have a lifestyle brand
that encourages people to spend more
than the average person makes in a day
on Jade vaginal suppositories come visit
the toughest most secluded health nuts
in the world
the jabari tribe yeah Argentinians they
don't need to shove shiny rocks in their
insides to achieve a youthful glow they
just bury their coma patients in an inch
of all-natural snow and it's good as new
have you ever wondered how it feels when
your employees and extended family are
forbidden to make eye contact with you
experience the thrill of having your
alpha status ripped away by standing in
the presence of tribe leader in Baku do
not engage him in a staring contest
not because he'll bark at you
he'll do that regardless but because
it's like staring into the Sun a fake
chocolate son looking to find some
vacation romance look elsewhere no one
in Wakanda wants you this is a country
populated by the most intelligent
beautiful people you have ever seen and
again I cannot stress this enough their
King is also a superhero who looks like
this even as genocide Oh evil cousin can
get it that panic you feel when you
realize negging won't get you on base
priceless when was the last time anyone
looked at you with anything other than
fearful adoration in Wakanda
you'll get side-eyed hundreds of times a
day did you shoot a car into space
that's cute
meet the 16 year old master of nanotech
who can heal bullet wounds overnight
have you mastered all of the buttons on
your imported Japanese toilet
well Condon's haven't used physical
buttons in decades you'll have no idea
where to shoot so colonizer are you
finally ready to feel less dead inside
what Conda is for you but don't take my
word for it listen to these testimonials
I always assumed my technology would
shape the future until I visited Wakanda
and realize my life's work was a pile of
useless Jacque it's so refreshing to be
a directionless shell of my former self
I take the self-esteem annihilation tour
four times a year before that I had to
eat a live bear just to remember what a
challenge felt like it is with deep
humility and gratitude that I apologize
for my past braggadocio and submit
myself before the majesty of the
wakandan people
I thought robot shooting at me was a
challenge but have you seen this place
when you shoot them it actually makes
their catsuit stronger I want my mom so
awesome what Conda our borders are open
and we're ready to make you feel like
for the first time and probably your
whole life the first 10 guests will get
to rub the head of a dorm illogic just
kidding but seriously do not approach
the dorm illogic for any reason they
will destroy